aaron and i are both very methods so we
did a lot of pub fights first bullet
train is speeding into theaters and into
the hearts of action lovers
probably because the concept is so epic
ready to find out just how difficult it
is to film on a train number one
sometimes the most difficult stunts
aren't the ones that include kicking
teeth in since the movie was filmed on a
soundstage and not on an actual moving
train trying to emulate things like
speed can be a real challenge director
david leach said the hardest stunt
technically was getting the guys to fly
out the train door it was pretty hard
making the physics look right we were on
a soundstage we had to have stuntmen on
a wire three riggers and pullers and
then the choreography was changed at the
last minute the night before we were
going to kick them out the door but the
set wasn't really built for it this is
david's bread and butter though so he
handled the situation with ease saying
i've had so much experience in stunts i
knew we could do it i made the stunt
team stay light and put up the rigging
and rehearse it in the extra hours then
we got there and shot it in the morning
but it was not rehearsed we just did it
on the fly and we leaned in and we got
it number two is padding the gaffer's
job we don't know but we're going to
blame them for this aaron taylor johnson
lost a chunk of his hand but he was
prepared for the danger admitting after
when you sign up for a david leech movie
you know you're gonna get a couple
battle scars he was dropkicked across
the room and his hand caught on a sharp
bit where there was no padding what he
wasn't prepared for was the part where
he passed out saying i literally went
wham passed out and then i came back and
was like should we go again and they
were like no no no you gotta go get
stitches at the hospital so then i spent
the night in the hospital gaffers are
lighting control specialists we were
wrong to blame them maybe we can blame
rigging instead number three a fight at
the concession stand isn't all that
special have you been to a play with
only a 15 minute intermission one fight
between aaron and brad was changed from
one train car to another pretty last
minute this was hard on everyone because
each of the three train cars was
designed with different abilities the
director found it would be more fun to
have the scene set in the concession car
and they could have a fun gag with the
concession girl you know what do you
have anything sparkling
but the director said problem is that
set wasn't made to fly the walls
couldn't move so logistically you got a
camera operator in there you got a china
ball light and you got sound and you're
trying to move and fight and that was
hard number four luckily the cast was
prepared for a last minute changes they
taught the entire cast to throw punches
with both hands rather than learn just
complicated choreography sequences so
that in case when they got to set and
the director potentially changed his
mind the actors were prepared brad pitt
was doing all his own stunts well 90 to
95 anyways david leach went from brad's
stunt double to director pitt said he
trained me for those fights and in a way
he was helping me develop the character
now he's a director with his own voice
and own vernacular and i'm serving him
he's the boss so there was a beautiful
symmetry for two old friends despite all
the training brad accidentally got brian
in the nads on multiple occasions while
filming one stunt scene
now the director would prefer to have
the cast do their own fighting bad bunny
had pretty much no prep time and by the
end was wielding a knife like a trained
assassin the bad bun admitted it was
intense three weeks of training and
fighting getting ready with a lot of
physical exercise and choreography
nobody was damaged maybe it was the
adrenaline but i wouldn't have cared if
i had been hurt by brad pitt number five
if you get sick playing video games
you'd definitely get sick filming this
the led panels that were used to make it
look like the train was moving were
messing with joey king's head she said i
never got motion sickness but what did
happen is you know that feeling when
you're sitting in a parked car and the
people next to you start backing up and
you feel like you're going forward
you're like
sometimes i got that feeling and i was
like oh [ __ ] she may not have suffered
from motion sickness but the crew did
number six the pressure's on when you
choose to do an accent different than
your own expect heavy criticism joey
king spent up to three hours a day
perfecting accents for the role yes
accents she wanted options to share with
the director all of that aggressive
preparation may have come from her
imposter syndrome getting the best of
her thanks to brad pitt's presence
so she didn't drop the accent while
filming she stayed in it all day it sure
fooled brad because the first two weeks
he thought she was british brian also
got to do a british accent and put
himself through the ringer because he
could not embarrass himself in front of
his black british friends i didn't call
them fries i called them chips number
seven finally actors who are honest
about how much they're being slapped
around brad would rather take the real
hit if it means getting a good shot but
seriously everybody got hit in the face
everybody you asked yes everybody
number eight trains are hard to film on
how do you make a movie set on a train
visually interesting for two hours
the parameters became the opportunity
you have to use everything and anything
to your advantage like a laptop armrest
or some chopsticks in a fight taylor
johnson likes when there are boundaries
and limitations because then you can use
the environment to your advantage
working with different platforms meant
getting creative they had to be used as
multiple locations and they had to be
put together efficiently so that they
could be redressed it still blows me
away like what art department
construction
and visual effects pull off number nine
playing dead but you don't get no treats
logan lerman struggled with playing dead
for so long but he took inspiration from
weekend at bernie's brian tyree henry
said it's a true testimony to an actor
because playing dead is not easy telling
a story while your body is being moved
and jostled all over the place a lot of
our corpses in this movie did a great
job number 10. that line from aladdin
comes to mind
hiroyuki sonoda found the confined space
difficult to navigate especially with so
many people on the train because you're
not just dealing with actors but the
crew on board too it's probably better
they built their own trains rather than
work on one that isn't adjustable tyree
henry had the same concern saying you're
like how is the camera gonna get through
down this aisle how are we gonna hide in
this toilet number 11. is it a pokemon
or a digimon saucy beets had to climb in
that momomon costume for at least a day
and she found that it was hot and
difficult to work in luckily she mostly
got to pass that work off to the stunt
team
number 12. it must suck being so famous
that everybody's intimidated by you
hiroyuki sanada struggled to keep up
with brad pitt's improvising saying i
had to carefully listen i was scared was
he scared to miss his next line or was
he scared he wouldn't realize an
adjusted line would lead to a fist to
the face yeah he was just intimidated by
pit hiroyuki wasn't alone though joey
king was also a wee bit nervous she said
i've been doing this for a long time but
when i was with such heavy hitters in
that movie and david leach directing
this movie i showed up to set being like
hey i felt like a kid on the first day
at school i was like i don't know
anything about acting apparently so i'm
really excited to be here what a quirky
crazy dangerous movie huh we commend the
whole team for being able to pull off
such an original idea
don't mention snow piercer or murder on
the orient express this is a totally
original concept right were you happy to
be along for the ride or did you find
the setting got a little
repetitive let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things